I reject nation it's greg alba here then
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch
today poster enough and you see it asked
me I think I'm more thrown off when you
only say your first thing
official trailer they had a teaser
trailer that came out a few months ago
which looked pretty cool to me back when
this still belonged to the WB yeah and
it's Comeau Glee legend of the jungle
welcome jungle this trailer dropped
10:00 p.m. our time last night and woke
up was like what the hell and we like
research [ __ ] yeah kind of happened that
I had no idea that you know when the
Warner Brothers sold it to Netflix and
now Netflix is gonna release this it's
pretty crazy
especially because Warner what I don't
like a trailer and everything for it so
I just can't oh gosh so it's pretty
surprising anyway before we hop into
this I wanted to say muchos Gracias to
everyone who has been doing their job
and following us on the Stardust app
that's an app that has 30 second
reactions that has so many youtubers on
there for films TV shows and trailers
people say reactions but they're also
reviews we do micro sketches over there
it's a whole lot of fun and you should
follow us today you see this thing use
that URL not John Bailey's hours follow
us first then follow John Bailey
[Music]
[Music]
great music
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
how cool I know that boys
Priyanka
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hopefully a subtitle it was there before
and in select theaters December 7th okay
the other big deals Netflix is caving
and putting their stuff in the theater
now instead of you know the way these
things really ought to be seen which is
on your you know television or phone
I guess this actually yeah I guess this
makes the bet the most sense and move it
because from my perspective like my own
personal I imagine yours too we would be
inclined to go check the size of the
theaters because this looks different
enough but then I'm also thinking in the
perspective of general audiences you
know who maybe not our film enthusiast
or whatever still could see something
like this that even though it feels
totally different there's still so many
elements that are the same I mean
granted like I don't recall the only
cell that jungle book live-action one
from Disney one time I don't recall any
of these elements with the Village
People yeah he's included in here much
more prominent it's such a important
part and I've always wanted the dark
ending of Mowgli of the jungle book from
what I learned about years ago you know
like takes the animals all the people
and there's I've always wanted that
ending it doesn't look like it's gonna
go down that path but I also like how in
this journey this tale he's conflicted
and caught between which world he
belongs to should he stay with these
people in the man or should he stay with
the animals you know his family who he's
actually grown up with yeah like you got
both of those elements in there and it
seems to be a real conflict it's like
part of the animal kingdom a lot a big
part of the kingdom except Simba then of
course you know you got people like Khan
village people I remember the teaser
show they had that one image where he's
like put in the jail okay yeah yeah yeah
this was a much more lively human world
glimpse and I mean it feels intense it
does and I also appreciate it just on
the contrast side you know like Andy
Serkis seems like a filmmaker with a
pretty thoughtful eye so I like the
glimpses we got into the human world
where it's you know celebratory and it's
kind of into their culture and whatnot
and I appreciate those elements I feel
like that's something that could set
this apart because yeah it's like I
imagine an average audience core might
look at this and go oh yeah the
live-action animals and stuff I just did
this like months ago so it's a little
sadder if they are at an odd position
but I do like that this trailer at least
went out of its way to show at least a
few things that the other movie didn't
give us quite the visual effects here
it's weird some of the wider shots don't
look as good that's when it looks fake
but the close-ups which are is usually
kind of in Reverse sometimes I notice
the wider shots look good and in the
close-up right here there were shots
that sometimes don't look like good CGI
and there are other moments you're like
that looks really good you know maybe
maybe he just figured like we're gonna
put the camera all up in this bear or
leopard or whatever yeah we're good I'm
the mocap guy yeah the major difference
it's like sure it's kind of got a darker
tint to it it still feels like a you
know colorful film not as like bright
and shiny and musically yeah yeah does
anyone this does feel like the gritty
version of the jungle book you know what
people forget there was a live-action
jungle book before the Disney one they
came out I think Disney actually
produced the one that I'm talking about
over Jason Scott Lee this exists yeah
he's not a boy he's a man but it's yeah
when are we gonna get like a double
feature you know like the Jason Scott
Lee one right before Jon Favreau one
right before the Andy Serkis one just do
a triple feature of jungle books I don't
remember that one all too well I saw
when I was younger it was I remember
there were some scenes that were a
little more like he like kills the snake
with a knife and stuff battles it
underwater
I don't know [ __ ] you guys were planning
on going to check that out of everything
the animals on talking that movie oh no
I bet they don't so this feels cuddly
God hi pretty Disney's live-action that
came out a couple years ago and that one
because I was little like goofy but more
mature and then be here you know you got
like oh we're really
honing in on it yeah the most realistic
version of this we could deal with
talking animals now animals in a badass
feral child yeah yeah I feel like what
everyone probably wants to talk about
her like the animals and everything but
the human story really does look very
interesting to me it's a completely
different element because man is
destroying the jungle man kills the
animals like they had that one shot with
that guy with the rifle about to shoot
down the elephant who I'm assuming he
kills which of course is gonna create a
very huge conflict for Mowgli like I
imagine he's gonna go with these humans
start bonding with them because he looks
like them this is probably where he
belongs and he's gonna see how they
treat the jungle and how he treat the
animals and it's gonna be a really
intense situation so I feel like there's
a lot to do Explorer that would be so
different than the Disney one yeah but
Disney want at least the recent one you
know the the human element is a part of
it but it seems like this is gonna make
it a much larger part of it and yeah I
can definitely see it being such that
Mowgli will eventually get very torn and
I don't know if it would end up where
the actual story ends up I feel like
that may still be a bit dark for the
wide-release
audience or even still I can imagine
that there'll be some kind of difficult
compromise between Mowgli's human side
and his animal side and that's pretty
fascinating about this having that human
element be so big in here and then
having it seem like it will lead to such
a conflict does yeah it's an edge
separating it from the Jon Favreau when
it leaves I was gonna say Andy Serkis
blue I think so yeah yes all the voices
are like British or Australian or
something it's all Lord of the Rings but
then when he's like laughing you're like
blue at a bad day and you're gonna rip
your face off and eat all your picnic
food you know weirdly that I want to see
this now more than ever yeah yeah
especially given all these weird
circumstances cuz then this makes you
wonder like why did WB make this
decision did they just not have faith in
the movie and Disney made their own or
were they just like wow this is way too
close to what Disney had yeah or what
you know alright guys well that was a
whole lot of fun I'm excited to check
this
be out before we wrap this up I wanted
to give a page from the day shout-out to
a man named Luke Anderson Luke Anderson
him and I have been talking quite a bit
on patreon lately these guys all the way
from Spokane Washington he's been
watching her channel for like almost
five years now so thank you so much for
that and you know bonding with this guy
was really cool because him and I share
similar passion for film especially in
where it's stem from we bully like he
was telling me that he really inherited
from his dad he was like first movie he
remember seeing the theatres he was like
three and watch Free Willy
mine was Jurassic Park we both watched
animal-based movies this guy actually
he's do really well in life he's a
private car 22 he's a private contractor
for FedEx and I was like 20-something
employees yeah also getting a touch into
his mindset like he's not he looks for
people who he can give opportunities to
it looks for people like he really likes
to think outside the box and over the
fact they both meditate I I'm really
glad that after five years we finally
get to know each other Luke appreciate
being our patron page did nothing but uh
since you're shadow
what kind of high-fives do people give
when they're like just bonding over
meditation because like it's such a
mellow activity it seems a way to just
be like yeah yeah you know each other on
the bottom alright guys well thanks for
tuning in are you gonna check out Mowgli
welcome to the jungle yeah yeah we're
Mowgli gets dropped in and he turns in
Johnson saves a duel it's perfect you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell and check
us on the start oh snap people free
download free to use do now do it to it